so i go back to uh to
jersey and i'm lost and no job
but here's the funny thing like i was
like on the point of being homeless but
i always had cocaine
you ever been in that situation
like i was always living on somebody's
floor but i always had an ounce of coke
i never understood that
now in hindsight like why didn't i sell
that coke and get a [__] apartment
because my overhead was gonna kill me
was too much for my addiction
800 a month in rent i can't spare it
though i can't [__] hustle i'd rather
put that in my nose and figure something
the [__] out
so this is all going on i'm living on
people's couches and [__]
nobody's trusting me i can't find a job
and i start front and coke from
different dealers and i'm lying to all
of them i'm going to go to miami and
pick up but i had nothing going on
but i owe like 20 [__] thousand so i
had this uncle
i had this uncle who i really really
loved as a kid in fact i used to come
out here
i started coming out to california but
from the age of seven to ten i would
come twice a year
and i would go to raider games and i
would go to [__] dodger games
and i would go to sea world and
disneyland by myself my mother would put
me on a plane
and my uncle had a bar here in fact he
still has the power on [__] vermont
so i always loved my uncle you know and
he was my mother's brother
and i knew that he would take me in like
in the back of my head growing up in
jersey
i always knew that something went bad
even before my mother died i'd come to
california
that was like the dream in the back of
my head always i was always gonna end up
in california
because my uncle was here and he was a
musician and i liked music
and i would come out and visit him and i
would go to his band and watch him play
with santana
and i mean he was [__] great this guy
so
uh i figured i'd come out here and i
tell him my story
and maybe he could help me out so i call
him up i tell him the truth and i need a
plane ticket
and i come out to l.a and he he tells me
he's gonna pick me up at lax
never [__] picks me up i gotta take a
cab to his bar he's not there
like he's kind of ducking me and this is
the uncle i was tight with growing up
all those years we stuck on the phone
all the time we called and talk about
music whatever
so finally i go to his bar and he's not
there all morning like i slept in the
street that night i didn't know l.a
i knew nothing about it his bar was on
[__] vermont and washington
i knew nothing yeah damn is [__]
right
so i go down i put my little army bag
and my suitcase and i sleep outside
and next morning they come to open it
and i'm like where's my uncle like he
doesn't come until two in the afternoon
so i just waited there all day for my
[__] uncle and he shows up and he's
like i don't have time for this [__]
he goes i'm happy you came out here so i
can tell you how i feel he goes you know
you
we were in cuba and your mom my sister
and her boyfriend your father left
and they went to new york and god knows
what they were doing you know we had
words that they were selling heroin
here my uncle's telling me all this [__]
and i'm like [__]
you used to go to new york and snort
with them at that [__] house
i used to see you snort with my mom and
drinking and spending twenties and [__]
we used to go to mec games he's a san
francisco giant fan and a dodger fan
so he would fly to new york just to go
to baseball games with my mother
i would see him doing [__] coke and
he's telling me this [__] one day he's
like you know
i don't know if you're doing drugs or
not but it's in your genes you're never
gonna amount to nothing
he's like it's just the way it is in
life he goes you're just never going to
amount to nothing he's telling me all
this and i'm like
this is my [__] uncle and he's like
you don't understand
your mother and your father sold heroin
as kids with that girl as a writer he's
the one that told me
and he goes they became millionaires and
they did this and this and this there
was a big party
and i'm like [__] but you were spending
the money too before my mother died he
would always call my mother hi i want to
renovate the [__] bar
send me money so my mother always said
maybe i'll go partners with him
in his bar in l.a why here my mother
dies this [__] never even sends
a 20 out
and now he's calling me all these
[__] names so he's telling me you
know what
you're just gonna maybe be a thief or
something like that and i got so pissed
off in my head i'm gonna rob this
[__]
he called me a [__] thief i'm gonna
rob this [__]
and in those times i used to carry i
used to travel like a little 38
it was a little one i put on my [__]
those days there was no [__] flights
or nothing you couldn't fly with a gun
like clint eastwood on a plane but you
could put it in your bag and they would
say do you have anything in your bag you
could lie to him
you're supposed to travel with a weapon
with a case but i would always go i got
nothing
but i would have like 10 guns in there
you know
bullets separated you couldn't have the
guns in the bullet the bullets and the
guns
you have to like have them separated in
case the cop if they did check my
luggage i gotta always lie out of it i
didn't know officer
you know me i'm [__] you know
yeah yeah i don't know nothing i don't
know nothing i don't have cable tv
officer you know me
just when the cosplay you don't know
nothing you don't know you don't even
know your [__] name my name i have no
[__] idea
i don't know nothing officer so i was
just i had this little 38.
so he kept calling me names because i
tell you what why don't you help me
bartend tonight
and if you were like he just insulted me
guys you haven't just been
[__] rudely insulted he's like if
you're any good as a bart because i told
him i'm bartending in new york
he goes if you're any good i'll let you
stay upstairs for a few days
and make a little money and i asked him
i go can you lend me two thousand
dollars just trying to get an apartment
here in a little car
to get around it was the 84 the olympics
were going to be here and they were
hiring like crazy
and i even took a bus like two buses i
don't even know where the [__] i went
to do the paper i didn't have no
felonies then so i get a job at the
[__] olympics you follow me
so i want now i can't get a job with not
even the post office
nobody will [__] hire me because i
got felonies but then i had no felonies
so i went down they're like we'll hire
you
you're gonna carry benches and [__] like
that for like eight weeks i didn't give
a [__]
i just wanted to get out of jersey guys
i wanted to do something with my [__]
life
i knew i was stuck in a rut i just
wanted to do something and this
[__] my own blood is insulting
me this [__]
telling me i'm never gonna mount to none
at least like if you're halfway good
i'll let you [__] stay a couple weeks
so i said [__] it
no i go i mean the shift i go no no i
don't want to stay on one of my buddies
i had nobody in l.a
i was just robbing him for every beer i
sold he got a dollar and i got a dollar
that's the way it goes everything i saw
we split it right down the middle
[__] it that's how i roll i had money
everywhere i had money in my balls my
sock
my back pockets my stomach i had it in
my [__] under my tit
in the [__] arm you ever have your
grandmother she has a money and a
[__] bra
i had it everywhere i had money [__]
everywhere
and every 15 minutes i go i gotta go to
the bathroom i'd empty it out and i'll
take the garbage can out and put it
under the [__]
trash so he can never find it i'm a
[__] savage
i'm robbing this [__] i'm
giggling the whole night he's like
look at you you're [__] too slow and
all this [__] and i'm laughing i got you
[__]
so he goes all right i'm gonna leave he
had a mistress at the time because i'm
gonna leave with my mistress
you could sleep upstairs you earned your
keep putting that gives me like 40 bucks
but i know i got like 1500 in that
wastebasket downstairs
so i go upstairs i turn the light off
it's this little [__] bed
it was like sandusky's basement
it was where he [__] his mistresses it
smelled like [__] and feet you know
what i'm saying
there was chains there was like a big
yellow stain in the middle of bed
you gotta like [__] avoid it you have
a void like the other
i'm up there like laughing like this
[__] i know i got them for 1500
downstairs
i go downstairs i open up the door i go
to the [__] bathroom as i'm coming
out with my money counted he's right
there at the door
he goes something made me come back here
i forgot my wallet or something
and what are you doing in my bar give me
my money back so lucky i left like 300
in my sock
he goes i'm going to call la police and
i pulled the gun on him he pulled the
gun on me it was [__] scary
so he goes leave the money and i won't
call the cops and get the [__] out of
here i'll call you a cab
i never want to see you again i go [__]
you [__] i do want to see you
again for what you said about my mother
and my father and my [__] me i'm
gonna come back and shoot you you
[__]
and i meant it i was pissed i [__]
left i went back to jersey and i would
call this [__] long distance
and tell him
because when i talk english to you
that's one thing but when i call you and
say something in spanish you're [__]
done you understand it
i would tell
even when they put me in prison in 87 i
would call them from the [__] jail
they were
i was gonna kill that [__] dog i
was